[Applause]
[Music]
now let's give a warm welcome to the
artistic director emeritus of the Alvin
Ailey American Dance Theater Judith
Jamison thanks how are y'all
yeah you know you've just been to church
you just saw a baptism yes this is from
this wonderful piece mr. Earley created
in 1960 called revelations mr. Ali was
29 years old when he choreographed this
masterpiece it's been danced all over
the world and understood universally
because he understood the humanity in us
all revelations is a reflection of a
journey we all take in life and
hopefully triumphantly that was the
magic of Alvin Ailey he was able to see
you in the audience see me as the dancer
and see the connection between us and
choreographed works that connect us all
so you felt he was telling your story
while I felt I was dancing mine I
started dancing when I was six years old
in Philadelphia I was skinny dark
chocolate and a kid with legs up to my
armpits and the very first performance I
had at the Judah Meyer School of Dance
was in a red checkered shirt dungarees
pink ballet shoes and we were dancing
too I'm an old cowhand from the Rio
Grande I loved every minute of it I mean
I literally did loved every minute of
especially when I heard the applause and
I knew right there when I was six I said
that's for me
at 6:00 you're not thinking that's gonna
be a career of your lifetime but that
was perfect for that moment I danced my
way through school and through college
and it still didn't dawn on me that
that's what I actually wanted to do I
went to an audition which I was dreadful
energy on the audition I've had in my
life and when I was let go from that
audition because I thought when they
were saying thank you very much that
meant for me to stay I ran up the steps
and there was a man sitting on the steps
and I barely noticed him he was an
observer
three days later that man called me and
asked me what I like to join the Alvin
Ailey American Dance Theater that's how
it happened folks this is there's no
drama or trauma
so I spent 15 years dancing with the
company and then I directed it for
something like 21 years if you were
black and african-american and a dancer
any time between the 40s and the 70s you
had much to say because your complete
voice was not being heard and you are
not being represented as you truly were
a Vannelli had the courage right in the
middle of the civil rights movement to
present the truth about who we were that
our creativity our beauty our
intelligence our talents were an
intrinsic part of the panoply of
American culture our mantra has always
been to educate to entertain and to lift
our audiences mr. Ellie believed that
dance came from the people and needed to
be delivered back to the people we
didn't dance in a vacuum it was our
mission to serve people we called it
outreach now but it's always been a part
of who we were and still are 60 years
later to this day being inclusive of our
audiences it's always been a an
important part of the company we ask
ourselves who are we dancing for why are
we dancing it's not to show people what
it is to be human
and to connect with the audience's that
we dance for we've always felt
responsible to make sure the community
understood that what we do is a part of
their heritage we just don't do this
also in America we do it all over the
world we tour more than any other dance
company in the world after Nelson
Mandela was released from prison I
thought well this is the time to go to
South Africa and that was some outreach
we went to Johannesburg Soweto and some
other townships they were really in dire
straits and it dawned on me as we were
there I'm going like here we are in the
sea of mother Africa and we're trying to
teach these people how to dance but it
was our African American nests that they
were interested in the culture that we
have developed over the last 400 years
we toured all over the world many times
and whether we're in Europe or South
America or Asia or somewhere else
audiences are thrilled and excited you
sounded thrilled and excited sometimes
with tears in their eyes because this
nonverbal communication really works and
it's about embracing everyone Alvin
didn't need to explain to us what was
going on at the time in the 60s 70s it
was obvious why we were doing his work
he knew what the truth of the time was
about and he was unafraid to reveal it
through dance he tapped into every
emotion he had and we had and from
angerness to happiness to grief and
everything in between he knew us he took
our history and turned it into powerful
dance he and I overlapped generationally
we didn't have to talk about things so
much because we understood implicitly
our shared responsibilities so when he
asked me to take over the company before
he passed in 1989 I felt prepared to
carry it forward Alvin and I were like
parts of the same tree he
the roots in the trunk and we were the
branches
I was just Beus we were all his muses
the ballet cry which some of you might
have seen you're gonna see an excerpt of
it it was made on me and Alvin dedicated
it to all black women especially our
mothers when Alvin and I went in the
studio of course he wasn't thinking I
Here I am creating an iconic work do you
know any artist that does that you don't
go into the studio to create anything
but what's coming truthfully from your
heart and your spirit and you trust that
you have a dancer you can share that
with rehearsal space is a sacred space
not to be intruded upon because it's
about talking to each other through
spirit you better have some technique on
top of that so you can do that
he brought his Alvin to cry and I
brought my duty to it I just did the
steps and this was a birthday present
for his mother because he couldn't
afford to get her a tactile gift when I
performed it the first time it was
physically and emotionally draining I
hadn't yet run through the whole piece
from beginning to end the ballet is 16
minutes long it's about a proud woman
who has been to hell and back from her
journey across the Atlantic she's
exhausted she's a queen and in this
section you're going to see she is
triumphant she made it and she is in
that last step that she does beating
away anything negative with her
tremendous strength and then the last
step she's digs into the earth and she
reaches into the sky because she's
clearing space for the next journey
I performed it in 1971 and we are still
clearing space now let me leave you with
one last thought here we are in the 21st
century still fighting for civil rights
not a day goes by that we are not made
aware of the struggle that continues I
believe that dance can elevate our human
experience beyond words and when you're
sitting in the dark in the theater
having a personal experience
you don't feel blocked or misunderstood
you feel open alive and we hope inspired
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]